choose sine of 2x equals 1 how do we
solve this problem well it's just like
solving an algebraic equation in the
sense that what you want to do is you
want to get the trig function by itself
so we're trying to get the sine of 2x by
itself first so let's go ahead and do
that by dividing both sides of the
equation by 2 okay so now we have sine
of 2x equals 1/2 now what we're gonna do
is we're going to treat this quantity
here this angle as a group as a chunk so
we're gonna say sine of what angle
equals 1/2 now we're gonna go to the
unit circle and if you need some help
reviewing the unit circle I'll put a
link to a video I talked about how to
master the unit circle and give you some
practice with that so check that video
out but we're going to jump into this
sine of 2x equals 1/2 now remember the
sine is the y-coordinate and on the unit
circle where does the Y value equal 1/2
well you can see that's going to be a 30
degree reference angle that's going to
be right here and it's also going to be
in the second quadrant right here okay
now what we want to do is we're gonna
write this as a general solution and so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
say that 2x is equal to PI over 6 which
is 30 degrees plus 2 pi N where n is an
integer meaning you know you can add 2
pi that's like going once around the
circle you can add another 2 pi another
2 pi or you could add like a negative 2
pi a negative 4 pi if you keep going
around 2 pi that's one revolution you're
gonna end up in the same point on the
circle where the sine value the
y-coordinate is going to be equal to
positive 1/2 now also over here this is
at 150 degrees or 5 PI over 6 so let me
write that down 2x equals 5 PI over 6
plus 2 pi n again because if you add 2
pi you go once around the circle you end
up in the same spot you get that sine
value of 1/2 but we're not interested in
solving for 2x we're actually solving
for 1x so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to divide this by 2 everything on
the left and right sides by 2 so if we
do that you can see we're solving for X
but now what we're getting is we're
getting PI over 12 plus pi N and here
we're getting 5 PI over 2
Plus high-end and that's our general
solution for what x equals
we just circle that for us now if the
instructions said you know not to get a
general solution but just to solve for
all the angles to satisfy this equation
from zero to 2pi say for example like
this 0 to 2pi including 0 but not
including 2pi so once around the unit
circle what you would actually do is you
would list the angles going around the
unit circle twice now I'll show you why
twice like say for example this here you
can see is a PI over 6 this over here is
5 PI over 6 this over here would be
let's see that's 2 pi plus another PI
over 6 so what's that that's 13 PI over
6 and then over here we would have how
much would this be this would be 12 plus
17 PI over 6 right but the thing is is
what we actually solve for is we solve
for 2x so we would then do is we divide
all these angles by 2 and that would
still keep you within C 17 by PI over 12
that still just once around the unit
circle so even though we went around
twice when I found these four angles
because we actually are dividing by two
that's going to keep us within the
restricted domain here of 0 to 2 pi so
let's jump into another example so you
can see how this works so number 2 it
says 3 tangent squared of 4x minus 1
equals 0 so just like solving an
algebraic equation we want to isolate
that tangent we want to get that tangent
by itself so what we're gonna do is
we're going to add 1 to both sides okay
so we have 1 and now we have 3 tangent
squared of 4x we're to divide both sides
by 3 okay to get that tangent by itself
so now we're down at tangent squared of
4x equals 1/3 we're going to take the
square root of both sides because we
just want to get tangent by itself so
now we have tangent of 4x equals plus or
minus 1 over the square root of 3
because square root of 1 is 1 square
root of 3 is square root of 3 and if we
rationalize this you can see we're
getting plus or minus square root of 3
over 3 now remember when you take this
critter both sides you get two answers
plus or minus so now we're going to do
is we're gonna go to the unit circle and
we're going to say to ourselves okay
where does tangent equal
square root three over three and I
remember tangent is the Y value divided
by the x value so we're gonna be looking
at let's see this is going to be right
here at the 30 degree reference angles
and the reason is is because see this
point is square root 3 over 2 comma 1/2
tangent is y over X you can see we're
getting 1/2 over square root 3 over 2 if
we multiply the top and bottom by 2 see
how we get 1 over square root of 3 which
is what we had here and then if you
rationalize you're gonna get square root
3 over 2 over 3 but now here's the thing
if we want to write this as a general
solution what you want to do is you want
to look at these four points and one
thing to pay attention to is that you
see how these are across from each other
that's an important distinction there so
you can see this is PI over 6 okay so
for X we actually are solving for this
angle 4x equals PI over 6 plus PI n now
PI is just 180 degrees it's just a half
a revolution so every time we add PI we
end up at this point another PI would
end up at this point and so on if this
one if we were to add PI you can see
that there's not a corresponding point
that's 1/2 revolution you know around
the circle from that point so we were
having to add 2 pi 1 full revolution
here we're just adding 1 pi so we've got
4x equals PI over 6 plus PI an and we
also have 5 PI over 6 plus PI n is equal
to 4x now we want to just solve for one
X I'm going to divide everything by 4
okay both left and right sides and so
that comes out to what that's PI over 24
plus PI over 4 n and x equals 5 PI over
24 plus PI over 4 n so that's our
general solution right there so that's
the key now let's go into another
example number three we've got 2 times
the cosine of X divided by 2 equals
square root of 3 so same idea here we're
trying to get that cosine by itself so
I'm going to divide both sides by 2 okay
so now we're asking ourselves cosine of
what angle I'm going to treat this like
a group cosine of what angle equals
square root 3 over 2 well remember
cosine is the x-coordinate right on the
unit circle so we're asking ourselves
whereas the cosine root 3 over 2 that's
again going to be at a 30 degree
reference angle see how this is root 3
over 2 comma 1/2 cosine is the axe but
we want to know where cosines positive
root 3 over 2 that's going to be over
here at 30 degrees and over here at 330
degrees so this one I'm gonna do in
degrees these ones I did in radians so
we're gonna say that x over 2 equals 30
degrees plus 360 add or we could say x
over 2 equals 330 degrees plus 360 n now
notice I'm not adding a hundred eighty
degrees because that would put us over
here and there's not a corresponding
point where cosine equals square root 3
over 2 but now let's take it one step
further let's multiply both sides by 2
to get X by itself okay so if we do that
we're gonna get x equals 60 degrees plus
720 and and if we multiply this side by
two we're gonna get 660 degrees plus 720
and okay now if they just said find all
the solutions from 0 to 360 meaning you
know once around the unit circle here if
we let n equals 0 you can see we're
getting x equals 60 degrees here if we
like n equals 0 we're going to be
getting 660 degrees which is not in our
restricted domain of 0 to 360 right so
you would only just get one solution
here just 60 degrees if that was the
restricted domain but here if we're
writing this as a general solution you
know we can just have it written as 60
plus 720 n or 660 Plus 720 ad okay let's
go into a fourth example here now so
number four we've got five secant
squared of 3x equals 10 so hmm so how
are we gonna solve the same idea we're
gonna divide both sides by five we're
trying to get that secant by itself so
that comes out to two so we're saying
secant square root of 3x is equal to two
secant though is really one it's the
reciprocal of cosine 2 is like two over
one but now I'm going to do is I'm going
to take the reciprocal of both sides of
this equation so if I do that I get
cosine squared of 3x is equal to 1/2 if
I take the square root of both sides
remember you get two answers plus or
minus square root of 1 is 1 square root
of 2 we can rationalize this this is
going to be root 2 over root tubes like
that which is square root 2 over 2 plus
or minus and so that's saying the cosine
of 3x okay so now let's go to our unit
circle so where does cosine equal
positive or negative root 2 over 2 okay
if we draw our unit circle cosine is the
axe it's going to be root 2 over 2 here
negative root 2 over 2 here negative
root 2 or 2 here pause this root 2 over
2 here but what's interesting about this
particular problem is that see these are
45 degree reference angles okay but
notice how these points are actually 90
degrees apart okay and so what we can do
if we write this as a general solution
is we could say 3 x equals PI over 4 so
45 degrees plus 90 degrees or PI over 2
radians times end that's what we're
doing is we're adding 90 degrees that
takes us to the next point where cosine
is equal to root 2 over 2 when we keep
adding 90 degrees and we keep basically
bouncing around to the next a
corresponding